[Musique]
c'est une histoire à peine incroyable
que vient de révéler la Voix du Nord
interpellé chez elle pour avoir insulté
Emmanuel Macron sur les réseaux sociaux
tout commence la semaine dernière
lorsque le président de la République
s'apprête à prendre la parole sur TF1 et
France 2 une habitante du Pas-de-Calais
décide alors de publier ce message sur
les réseaux sociaux va parler demain à
13h mais quelques jours plus tard trois
policiers se présentent chez elle après
ce message injurieux la femme peine
toujours à y croire je leur ai demandé
si c'était une blague c'est la première
fois que je suis arrêtée mais la terre
n'est pas une blague puisqu'elle a bien
été placée en garde à vue et sera jugé
au tribunal pour outrage et insultes
envers le président et risque jusqu’à 6
mois de prison et 22500 euros d'amende
alors garde à vue après avoir insulté
Emmanuel Macron sur les réseaux sociaux
trouvez-vous ça normal
trouver ça normal elle a donc on garde
la vue après avoir insulté manuel Macron
sur les réseaux sociaux trouvez-vous ça
normal oui oui je vais demander à
Mathieu tiens qui dit oui bah vous me
connaissez évidemment je trouve ça
normal moi je suis pour le retour alors
je suis pour l'uniforme à l'école je
suis pour que je te directeur arrive on
se levait on respecte les seniors on
respecte la police en société on
respecte tout le monde le Président
c'est même pas l'homme qu'on s'en fout
de Macron qu'on aime ou pas c'est une
fonction c'est une fonction elle en
comment on peut l'insulter il s'est déjà
fait gifler il sait qu'est-ce que c'est
que ce pays on est la risée de tous les
pays du monde on gifle le Président on
traite d'ordures et elle va regarder à
vue et c'est normal on doit respecter
nos institutions on les piétine sinon
voter différemment votez pour un autre
président changer de constitution mais
si vous votez pour cette constitution là
respectez-la ou aller en prison
c'est un peu violent moi je trouve qu'il
j'étais ici en train de dire que en
gifle pas un président et les
institutions c'est important jusque là
je te suis sauf que là il y a un
contexte un contexte il a mis les gens
il a mis les gens dans la rue il a mis
le pays en feu il a lieu aussi et
manquer de respect parfois au peuple
français il a lui aussi insulté le
propre le peuple français on a rien dit
là cette dame là pour moi elle sert
simplement d'exemple c'est tout il veut
ils veulent la punir pour dire attention
regardez maintenant si vous insultez le
Président si vous traitez le président
comme parce que c'est les on se bat pour
les retraites les gens les Français sont
en colère si vous l'insultez c'est garde
à vue ça inadmissible de mettre
quelqu'un qui a mis un message sur
Facebook alors démocratie ou pas
démocratique qui met des messages des
insultes de haine de harcèlement sur des
gamines du harcèlement sur plein de gens
des menaces de morts ils vont pas en
prison tu as des mecs qui tapent leur
femme ils vont pas en garder
j'ai des mesuré par rapport au contexte
19h56 une jeune femme passion garde à
vue trois policiers sont venus à son
domicile après qu'elle est qualifié le
président de la République d'ordures sur
les réseaux sociaux pour vous Valérie
Benaim c'est normal
qu'elle se retrouve en garde à vue parce
que il y a plus que ça en fait et nous
on se concentre sur les messages sur
Facebook mais en fait le préfet la
signaler c'est parce que il y a des
centaines aujourd'hui de gens qui
écrivent ordures en parlant de Macron ou
plein d'autres noms d'oiseaux pourquoi
on a été la chercher elle c'est parce
qu'on la soupçonne aussi d'avoir écrit
Macron ordures sur le dépôt de déchets
d'Arc et donc d'avoir déterré
un bien
publics
donc c'est pour c'est pour ça c'est pour
ça aussi évidemment que on va pas aller
chercher un par un tous les gens qui
aujourd'hui sur les réseaux sociaux
disent du mal du président parce que ça
en ferait un paquet donc je pense que
c'est pas simplement son petit message
sur facebook mais que c'est suspicion là
qui qui est détérioration de bien public
c'est pour ça qu'on est allé la chercher
je suppose enfin j'espère
oui bien sûr alors d'abord c'est faut
préciser quand même que c'est pas
Emmanuel Macron qui a porté plainte hein
et c'est pas un jour vis-à-vis du
président parce que ça n'existe plus ça
en France c'est quelqu'un dépositaire de
l'autorité publique et comme pour tous
les gens dépositaires de l'autorité
publique si elle avait insulté des
gendarmes des policiers ce serait la
même chose c'est pas possible mais
évidemment si c'est le préfet avait
signaler on ne peut pas tolérer que les
gens injuries traitent d'ordures des
représentants de quelques institutions
que ce soit si c'était un fonctionnaire
de police un gendarme j'aurais dit la
même chose alors elle ne sera pas
condamnée j'ai regardé les affaires
précédentes elle aura au maximum 1000
euros d'amende ou un rappel à la loi pas
plus
il y a des dizaines et des dizaines de
gens qui écrivent sur Twitter Instagram
Facebook des des des noms d'oiseaux sur
le président donc je pense que c'est
pour le respect de la loi c'est illégal
je crois pas que ce soit pour ça et si
en revanche si c'est moi je changerai je
mettrai non
elle peut dire ordure c'est quoi la
limite mais c'est quoi l'étape
d'aujourd'hui le contexte aujourd'hui
sur les retraites sur les manifs
aujourd'hui les gens sont sont exaspérés
ils ont pas plus ils explosent pas la
limite là tu prends tu prends du recul
et tu dis voilà cette dame elle est
énervée elle est en colère je m'en bats
les couilles je suis président je vais
passer ma retraite je vais passer mon 49
3 c'est comme ça je vous emmerde mais
c'est quoi la limite la prochaine fois
là c'est le comtesse qui me dérange
aujourd'hui
pour moi le sert d'exemple cette dame là
et quand j'ai dit 1000 € qui te dit
qu'elle les a les 1000 € à donner
le terroristes sur les réseaux sociaux
vous allez pas les chercher ces gens là
qui a fait des bras d'honneur à
l'Assemblée nationale est-ce que il a
été en garde à vue est-ce qu'il lui
arrivait quelque chose salut nazi dans
l'Assemblée nationale c'est un député de
la République en marche ok qui a dit
tiens bon on les aura ces connards qui a
dit je veux emmerder une partie de la
population qui a dit les fainéant les
illettrés les gens qui ne sont rien on a
même pas passé son temps à insulter la
population si parce que quand on veut
respecter
s'il vous plaît
c'est pas du tout le débat non c'est là
le débat c'est est-ce qu'on peut
insulter des personnes après voilà
exactement c'est pas ça l'histoire
tu dis pas après tu dis pas un président
non mais c'est pas ça la question un
président tu dis tu es con tu veux dire
espèce de connard bah c'est ça je suis
désolé on doit être respectable
trois policiers dans le contexte actuel
comme l'a dit Raymond chercher une dame
en garde à vue alors qu'il y a de la
délinquance partout
franchement on a que ça à faire
d'envoyer trois policiers chez une dame
on est fort avec les faibles et faible
avec les forts dans ce pays et ça doit
s'arrêter
on peut même pas discuter avec eux parce
que il mélange tout voilà il y a des
cité où il y a de la drogue et tout donc
c'est pas c'est vous vous mélangez tout
vous mélangez tu mélanges tout un pays
c'est pas un contexte un pays c'est un
pays de se respecter on est la cinquième
économie
on a parlez-en à Hollande notamment tu
verras il fait passer une période rien
qu'avec moi je prends par la Hollande
rien qu'avec lui mais il faut se faire
respecter les institutions c'est très
important lors c'est important et toi
qui a des enfants si on dit ordure au
Président c'est quoi la limite c'est
quoi l'étape d'après c'est Gilles qui
dit quand sa fille pique sur du contre
la pisse contre un mur c'est normal moi
pourquoi tu mets la ça du coup
pourquoi tu me mets là ça malade lui tu
as raison sur ce sujet et toi ta façon
tu es toujours non mais tu peux vivre
Antipolis
du Massachusetts non mais c'est vrai
pour ça que oui
ordure du président sur un poste
Facebook on parle pas du gif qu'est-ce
que tu as le droit de dire tu n'as pas
le droit de dire je n'ai pas le
président sinon tu vas en garde à vue
c'est n'importe quoi
d'insulter une insulte c'est un avenir
un peu dur
à la liberté d'expression et qu'on
s'occupe des gens qui foutent vraiment
la merde dans ce pays plutôt
à mon avis bravo Guillaume là il a
raison
on peut même plus donner son avis mais
c'est pas ça mais quand je parle avec
toi je parle avec un mec qui prend une
suce au Balto en train de bouffer des
cacas
tout à l'heure tu as dit on s'en fout de
Macron on va en garde à vue alors c'est
vulgaire c'est méchant c'est méchant
c'est quoi le Président c'est la
fonction j'ai pas traité d'ordure j'ai
jamais traité personne d'ordures
personne on sait ce que peut jouer
depuis un champ traité de quoi que ce
soit et pourtant je pense qu'il fait des
choses dangereux dans la main comme ça
en fait
Jean-Luc Mélenchon on dirait qu'il est
là mais c'est son ami
préciser que aujourd'hui à cause de ça
de cette info le top tweet a été fait
injure en hashtag ça a été le top tweet
il y avait un moment 14000 tweets donc
en fait ça a eu l'effet inverse en plus
donc c'est même contre-productif d'avoir
fait ça à plus d'injures pas moins d'un
jour j'ai le président de la chaîne qui
m'écrit elle se fout de notre gueule
l'américaine avec des smileys donc je
sais pas pourquoi il a dit ça c'est pas
d'accord bah voilà donc apparemment il
n'est pas d'accord il faut le président
de la chaîne mais tu sais puisque tu es
libre tu as qu'à dire que le président
de la chaîne est une ordure
on peut tout dire aujourd'hui faut avoir
une colère on insulte pas les gens comme
ça gratuitement je cautionne pas
d'accord
de répression il y a pas de problème au
moins ça cadrerait un peu les choses mal
à ce moment-là qu'il le fasse pour tout
le monde et tous ces gens et tous ces
jeunes qui se font
humilier harcelés menaces de mort
pourquoi est-ce que c'est que les flics
qui vont pour aller protéger notre
président mais il y a plein de gens qui
souffrent des réseaux sociaux il y a des
gens mais encore de ça donc c'est soit
c'est pour tout le monde sauf pour
personne parce que avant d'être le
président de la République il est quand
même censé être le modèle et l'exemple
des Français c'est pour ça que je dis
oui et non c'est à dire oui si
effectivement elle est en garde à vue
elle a été en garde à vue cette dame
parce qu'elle a simplement écrit un
poste sur Facebook mais encore une fois
ce n'est pas ce qu'on nous dit elle sait
pas parce qu'elle n'a elle a simplement
écrit un poste sur Facebook c'est parce
que le préfet a fait un signalement
parce qu'il a il y a une photo d'elle
devant un mur où il y avait écrit Macron
ordure sur un dépôt de déchets de la
ville d'Arc et donc il est persuadé
enfin en tout cas il la soupçonne
d'avoir dégradé et donc d'avoir
endommagé par par ce tag c'est pas la
première fois l'étudiante
on a été la chercher en cours d'espagnol
est-ce que vous rappelez de cette
histoire ça commence à faire beaucoup
dans la même situation il y a beaucoup
de gens qui ont subi la même chose et ça
devient vraiment irrespirable il y a
vraiment un problème à ce niveau là
voilà un problème oui ce que je
comprends pas chez Béatrice et que la
détestation du personnage d'Emmanuel
Macron
j'ai même pas le temps de finir
mais c'est même pas lui c'est pas lui en
tant que personne c'est ce qu'il
représente encore une fois il est c'est
l'autorité publique et contestée c'est
un outrage chez pire qu'une injure
ordure c'est impossible en France et
heureusement sinon il y a plus de
limites que ce soit écrit oral ça ne va
pas c'est pas possible on ne peut pas
dire ça n'avait pas lieu sous Sarkozy
c'est quand même quelque chose d'assez
nouveau ça n'existe plus c'est pas parce
que c'est le président il y avait des
attaques
mais il y en avait tout le temps
politique
la vraie question c'est est-ce qu'on met
quelqu'un exactement
pour ça je trouve ça effectivement
inacceptable voilà une fois qu'on a dit
qu'on pouvait pas insulter Président on
l'a dit mais honnêtement si on fait ça
effectivement ça c'est après ton tu as
ce que tu
découle non la la tuateur parce que tu
détestes Macron
la fille en cours d'Espagne
encore une fois on parle d'un poste sur
les réseaux sociaux si on doit mettre en
garde à vue tous les gens qui une fois
dans leur vie sans son prix à même pas
au président une personne représente de
l'autorité que ce soit dans la vraie vie
dans les manifs sur Twitter mais mettez
la moitié de la France en saison alors
mais tu vois en garde à vue ça me
dérange pas que tu mettes les gens qui
fassent des conneries sur les réseaux
sociaux en prison sur insta sur Twitter
les vraies insultes qui ne font des
déclarations
antisémite des propos terroristes
allez-y moi je dis bravo bravo allez les
chercher mais allez les chercher tout le
monde allez pas chercher une pauvre dame
parce qu'elle s'est arrêtée devant une
photo derrière il y a un mec qui a ta
gueule elle s'est pris en photo ce qui a
été contente et on soupçonne que c'est
elle qui oh les gars attendez aller
chercher les les salopards là qui
cartonnent les bonnes femmes et les mecs
qui tapent leur bonne femme allez les
chercher mettez-leur un peu de garde à
vue ça va les calmer il tape pour moi et
puis là on sera tranquille
tout le monde ah si l'appareil quoi
allez chercher tout le monde c'est trop
facile Daniel on a pas eu Daniel
qu'est-ce qu'on va regarder vous
pancartes s'il vous plaît oui Daniel moi
je pense que tu dis non oui alors moi je
pense que l'idéal ce serait par exemple
qu'elle reçoit une amende par la poste
non mais ça c'est sûr
éventuellement une amende mais pas une
garde à vue parce que vous savez que
dans les manifs en ce moment Daniel avec
la garde à vue pendant la pub ouais
je t'ai dit cette course dames vous
voulez lui mettre 1000 balles d'amande à
cette pauvre dame après tous les
salopards qui parlent sur les réseaux ça
n'a rien à voir arrêter les mecs
Daniel non mais c'est vrai tu es marié
moi je dis que ça mérite une amende pas
plus pour marquer le coup parce qu'on a
pas à faire des insultes sur mais en
revanche dans les manifs il y a
énormément de gens qui font des gestes
mais est-ce que tu peux finir ou pas
parce qu'évidemment dans les manifs en
ce moment il y a énormément de gens qui
font des violences qui sont en garde à
vue et qui ne sont pas condamnés parce
que c'est un geste politique et que les
juges ont décidé de ne pas condamner les
gestes politiques donc je suis désolé
une garde à vue pour juste le mot
ordures sur les sur les ça ne mérite pas
ça c'est pas deux fois de mesure voilà
c'est tout c'est un geste politique
c'est une parole politique à ce
moment-là si on considère que taper dans
des avec des pavés dans des vitrines de
sont des gestes politiques
avec une bonne femme qui est chez elle
sur son téléphone qui fait deux mots et
qu'on voit ça pour faire rire
arrêtez de faire n'importe quoi mélanger
pas
acceptable ce que dirait mon passeports
que tu sois chez toi ou pas ça c'est
presque du cyber-harcèlement
et je vous et je vous signale vous vous
rendez compte elle risque un an de
prison c'est pas moi exactement
mais vous vous rendez pas compte on est
en train tous de dire à chaque fois
attention au réseau sur les réseaux on
peut plus dire n'importe quoi et là ça
dépasse les bornes
elle a raconté Valérie qui s'appelle
Valérie c'est un problème avec le
correcteur de son téléphone voilà ce
qu'il y a alors je lui dis
là
puisque c'était donc vendredi dernier il
a environ 10h du matin Valérie ouvre la
porte de chez elle face à elle trois
policiers qui lui annonce qu'elle est
placé en garde à vue si elle pense au
début que c'est une blague je crois que
c'est une darka un petit d'ailleurs
est-ce que ce serait pas une darka elle
se rend compte que c'est bien réel
puisqu'elle est transférée au centre
hospitalier le plus proche pour
contrôler son état de santé avant
d'atterrir au commissariat elle est
soupçonnée donc d'avoir taguer macro
ordures sur le mur du dépôt de chez Dark
dans le Nord et 3 jours plus tôt la
veille de l'intervention du président à
la télé j'étais 13h à la poster sur son
compte facebook lors dure va parler
demain à 13h pour les gens qui ne sont
rien c'est toujours à la télé que l'on
trouve les ordures Valérie a raconté que
c'était un problème avec le correcteur
de son téléphone c'est bien moi qui ai
fait cette publication mais je voulais
faire un jeu de mots et écrire l'or dur
comme un œuf dur le correcteur a modifié
et je n'ai pas relu avant d'envoyer
d'ailleurs je ne le cite même pas mais
ça n'a pas convaincu bien sûr les forces
de l'ordre qui l'ont présenté au
procureur en fin de journée elle sera
jugée vous rendez compte c'est quand
même le 20 juin prochain
outrage envers une personne dépositaire
de l'autorité publique ce qu'elle
comprend pas c'est que sur les réseaux
de nombreuses internautes insultent le
président bien sûr sans pour autant être
interpellé et placé en garde à vue
auprès de la Voix du Nord Valérie
affirmait qu'elle partageait souvent des
vidéos de violence policière et
politique elle estime que on voilà on
est dans une période où l'intimidation
est forte et elle se fait sur les
militants alors je vous le dis ce qui
est dit aussi c'est qu'un commissaire en
même confié à la Voix du Nord c'est une
procédure qui n'est pas souvent
déclenchée surtout contre la personne du
président de la République mais les
outrages et insultent étant considéré
comme un délit la garde à vue peut être
décidée dans le cadre de l'enquête voilà
alors si on fait pour elle on se
retrouve
sur son facebook on va trouver quatre
commentaires 12 commentaires c'est ce
commentaire on a mis une dame en garde à
vue elle roule pas sur l'or et pas on va
lui demander des 1000 euros d'amende
alors que je suis sûr qu'elle a fait
rire quatre personnes son oncle et sa
tante et on la met en garde à vue tu
vois pour moi elle sert d'exemple c'est
tout c'est juste faites attention à ce
que vous faites c'est un délit je suis
d'accord
mais justement
mais quel est le message que l'État veut
faire passer en allant chez cette pauvre
dame elle est toquer chez elle ça fait
pitié et j'aimerais juste savoir dans le
conducteur de l'émission après il y a
l'appel à l'aide de Lucile poursuivi
pour deux ans par son harceleur en
liberté qu'il a menace vous l'avez fait
exprès de le mettre dans la même
émission
c'est un garçon parce que sinon bravo
aux équipes
bravo à vous on comprendra tous par la
suite au cours du déroulé de l'émission
que il y a deux poids
en liberté le
mecsons
sur le ton de l'humour ce qui montre
bien qu'elle voulait faire une vanne au
départ première chose deuxième chose
toutes les insultes et toutes les
attaques ne se valent ne se valent pas
on ne peut pas comparer hors dur ou
connard avec des des tweets racistes
antisémites des appels à la violence des
appels au meurtre donc voilà et moi
j'aurais rien qu'on parle aussi de la
presse soi-disant satirique qui se fout
de la gueule des politiques des
politiques des capitales
[Applaudissements]
combien de fois Sofia RAM a insulté les
gens et Paris donc ils ont la carte ça
passe non mais ils ont la carte oui je
te jure que c'est incroyable alors que
cette pauvre dame qui est gilet jaune
elle va se prendre 1000 € d'amende pour
faire avec les femmes vraiment
l'impression que c'est important
excusez-moi excusez-moi de vous dire ça
non mais là là sur ce coup-là ça c'est
le zèle d'un préfet je suis désolé je
suis désolé les gars là
mon avis les mecs vous rendez compte que
tu vas les taper à Toky à toutes les
portes qui disent en plus en vrai je
vous dis franchement ordure
voilà des insultes 50 insultes à la
suite franchement les mecs c'est pire
qu'une injures
il y a la loi il y a l'esprit de la loi
aussi exactement et puis l'allemand à un
moment on l'a vu que un moment tu es les
lois je pense que là elles sont un peu
vieilles tu vois toutes les lois je
pense à un moment il faudrait peut-être
se pencher sur pas mal de lois tu vois
parce que là je te dis que là ça c'est
des lois pour moi elles sont obsolètes
excuse-moi de te dire ça une noire
défendre parfois des délinquants qui
font des dents
mais Béatrice a raison il y a un mec qui
vient squatter chez lui
il vient chier dans son salon
la loi elle est en train de t'envoyer
dans le mur non mais je te dis ça
peut-être et moi j'applique la Loire
Béatrice s'il te plaît non non mais
Gilles qu'est-ce que tu avais déjà
je dis les squatteurs quand c'est pas la
période pas les squatteurs d'ailleurs
mais les locataires mauvais payeurs
c'est pas la période pour les expulsions
ne les expulse pas non mais au-delà de
ça non non tu avais parlé d'un autre
truc
vraiment on en met enfin
c'était des gens qui rentrent chez toi
en infraction n'importe quel jour de
l'année dès qu'ils sont chez toi tu ne
les vires pas tu laisses la loi affaire
tu laisses la police
qu'il avait dit non je sais plus je
t'avais demandé Gilles si des
cambrioleurs viennent chez toi tu leur
dis bonjour bienvenue faites comme chez
vous je sais plus je t'avais dit un truc
comme ça effectivement la police
il avait défendu le titre qui allait
défoncé
et toi tu seras encore
allô c'est Gilles Bernard
les couilles
qu'est-ce que vous faites il y a des
cambrioleurs qui viennent chez vous vous
appelez aussi
j'appelle la police mais moi aussi tout
le monde appelle la police
moi j'ai la chance d'habiter
[Rires]
la dernière fois m'a volé un pain au
chocolat je peux te dire que le mec il a
pris 15 ans de prison
normal non à 60